Great now that our
environment is set up,
let's start coding an interstitial ad.
The first thing we have to do
in our AdActivity Java code
is to set up our application key.
We do this by saying
AdRegistration.setAppKey and
then you'd put in your unique app key.
This key is given to you
when you register for
a game developer account through Amazon,
and it's unique for every app.
It helps identify your app, and
keep track of ad displays and
clicks that your app receives.
You'd usually use your own app key,
but since we're just doing a general
example, I'll use a sample
key that Amazon provides.
Now let's make our ad.
First I'm going to make a private
variable of interstitial ad type,
which we know is a class
in our Amazon ads library.
Then I'll give it a name,
InterstitialAd.
Now that we have our ad variable,
we're going to create an instance of it,
load it, and show it.
So back to our onCreate method.
I can create our ad by saying this,
then giving the variable name,
InterstitialAd equals a new
InterstitialAd object.
This ad object needs to know the
activity it's going to be used in, and
again that's just going
to be this activity.
That is to say,
our InterstitialAd activity.
Then I just need to add a line
of code to load our ad,
which is as simple as saying our
variable interstitial ad.loadad.
But what happens once this ad is loaded?
I'll have to create an ad listener
that will just listen to the ad and
decide what happens when it's loaded or
when it's closed.
To listen to our ad, we have to say
this.interstitial.ad.setListener,
and then we're going to
define a listener of our own.
So we're going to create an Internet
class called MyCustomListener,
and we'll just build off
the default add listener.
So we'll say MyCustomListener
extends default ad listening.
The listener notices what happens to
our ad at three different points,
which are methods in the listener class.
One point when the ad is loaded or
unloaded,
which takes in the ad object and
its properties as parameters.
A second point, if the ad fails to load,
which will throw an error message,
and a third point when the ad is
dismissed, that is when it's closed.
And we can write in
specific behaviors for
our ad or
app at each of these three points.
For example,
if our ad fails to load we might want to
put in code to call a backup ad network.
If our ad is closed, we might want to
put in code to resume our game.
But for now we're going to focus on
what happens once our ad is loaded.
Once our ad is loaded,
I'm just going to want to show it.
So to do that, I want to specify
the activity that it's in, and
then a reference to our ad object.
And then similar to loading the ad,
I just say .showad.
It's important that the show ad is
inside the on ad loaded method,
because we can only show
an ad after it's been loaded.
So if we put it up here and
it didn't load, we would get an error.
So this method is all we
really need to show our ad.
And the last thing we need to do is
specify that we're using this custom
listener of ours.
So let's replace this with
a new MyCustomListener object.